الانجاز التاريخي للمنتخب المغربي في
مونديال قتل 2022 يواصلوا اثاره اعجاب
المبدعين فيعبرون عن ذلك بلوحات جميله
حساب الفلسطيني عز الدين لولو عبر عن هذا
الاعجاب وتشجيع اسود الاطلس بلوحه فنيه
متحركه ونشر الفنان الفلسطيني ومقطع فيديو
عبر حساباته على منصات التواصل تضمن رسما
متحركه لخريطه الوطن العربي وقد وضعت على
مواقع منها صور مدمجه في بعضها لبعض لاعبي
المنتخب ولقطات لافته كالسجود الجماعي الى
افراد المنتخب بعد تسجيل كلها هذا
الله يا مغرب مغرب العروبه بين الامم يسعد
اشرف يسعد اشرف جول جول جول جول جول جول
جول
الله يا استاذ الله يا استاذ
[تصفيق]
برافو عليكم
من جديد
الابطال المستحيل ليس مغربيا
امسحي ليس مغربيا المستحيل ليس مغربيا
فعلها الابطال فعلها نسود نعم سيواصلنا
المشوار في هذا المونديال نعم كنت من هجوم
تتلالا في السماء قطر كنتم نجوم
تتلالا في السماء قطر برافو عليكم يا
ابطال ارفع راسك انت مغربي ارفع راسك انت
عربي ارفع راسك انت يا سيدي انت عربي يا
مسيحي مغربي اف
من التفاعلات التي رصدناها على هذه اللوحه
الفنيه نسمه قنديل تقول نسمه الابداع
يتخطى الحدود هي الموهبه اقوى رساله
ايضا كتب اسلام الاسطل المستحيل ليس
مغربيا
الانجاز التاريخي للمنتخب المغربي في
مونديال قطر 2022 يوصل ايضا اثاره
المعجبين فيعبرون عن ذلك بلوحات جميله كما
شاهدنا قبل قليل